zane pope in motion play action hit as  he throws and the ball goes backward  picked up makes fun of for the ducks  inside the well it didn't take long for  everyone to see just how special of a  player kayvon thibodeau is beginning the  2021 season creating a turnover leading  to a short touchdown run by cj burdell  you know that reminded me what judean  crowney did in south carolina when he  talked about possibly being the number  one pick he did it in michigan against  michigan in the bowl game and that was a  that was a special moment and he calls  thibodeaux calls to stir here today by  starting off the ducks getting their  first touchdown